quelques heures après l'annoncé
officielle de divorce du couple
présidentiel ces six-là sarkozy a tenu à
communiquer sur cet événement personnel
accordant successivement une interview
ce matin à l'est républicain
mais également un long entretien dans le
magazine elle à paraître demain
le président de la république de son
côté à lisbonne a coupé court à tous
commentaires souhaitant se concentrer
sur son activité publique en écoute
le chef de l'état walter d'esprit est
très simple j'ai été élu par les
français pour trouver des solutions à
leurs problèmes pas pour commenter ma
vie privée
si vous croyez que les français m'ont
élu pour autre chose que de travailler
travailler et encore travailler pour le
reste les français me demande aucun
commentaire ça les intéresse beaucoup
moins que vous
ils ont raison il peut être également
qu'ils ont plus de pudeur et plus de
discrétion
oserais-je dire un poil d'élégance en
plus